uh so next week there's gonna be a
pro-abortion speaker here talking about
how abortion is a moral good from a
christian perspective
how do you
yeah
how do you argue with someone who has
such an extreme
permission about abortion well i have an
extreme position about abortion which is
that it's bad to kill babies after
they're born or as they're being born or
just before they're born or really any
time before that they're born
i think that extreme position is easy to
hold and easily defensible
the question you'll have to ask is what
that person's premises are
because there are two points to that
topic one that abortion is a moral good
and two that it is christian
to kill babies
i seem to recall some verses of
scripture coming from
a what's a guy a guy named jesus christ
who talked about uh
he'll hold you accountable for whatever
you do to the least of these you know
and tie a millstone around your neck and
it'd be better right that that guy
so i'd be i'd be curious as to what he
says
i've never heard a coherent argument for
abortion
that did not also imply that it would be
perfectly fine to kill other
various human demographics one of the
arguments that cynical people make for
abortion is that it's good because these
kids they'll all be on welfare and
probably grow up and commit crime and
this is a very racist argument because
everyone who makes that argument is
saying that it's good to kill the little
black kids but you wouldn't want to kill
the precious little white kids who grew
up in the suburbs
and the question you have to ask him is
which young black man in an inner city
would you be willing to apply that logic
to at the age of 24
and look him in the eye because they're
never called out on the absolute racial
bigotry of it all in new york city more
black babies are killed in the womb than
are born that is horrific and future
generations will look on that barbarity
with great moral appropriation and we'll
look on the people who advance that with
great moral appropriation and if this
fellow is a christian then when he gets
to st peter's gate someday i have a
feeling that the eternal judge is not
going to look very well on him spouting
horrific heresy that has led people
possibly of good faith astray
he will he will meet the millstone
in in the next world and it would be
better for him to correct his views in
the present
all of that is to say
you should always take the level-headed
approach
do not you'll notice i'm i'm not uh
yelling or screaming about this man
i'm not yelling or screaming even about
abortion even as the governor of
virginia says we should kill babies
after they're born
because the truth is on your side you
don't need to
pretend that this is some
passionate interest battle that is
brutal and unreasoned
for him it is for you it's not
so i would calmly rip apart his
arguments
and
then i would advise him to go have a
quick confession and
and repent before the judgment day
we used to hear from democrats that
abortion was a very sad thing
something that i would never support but
i still think it should be politically
acceptable and legal
it should be safe legal and rare that's
what we heard in the mid 2000s from
hillary clinton now it seems that people
want to shout it from the rooftops there
there's nothing
wrong with abortion i mean the safe
legal rare thing never made a lot of
sense because if it's not wrong then why
does it have to be rare and if it is
wrong why should it be legal but so they
never they were trying to split the baby
if you will to use an apt metaphor what
changed what has empowered the left now
to so embrace abortion
well yeah i think as you mentioned this
safe legal and rare uh you know doctrine
that they were putting forth in 1973 all
up until the 2000s was kind of intended
to say
open the floodgates to abortion i think
they knew that people inside kind of
knew it was wrong they knew it was
something bad but they had to say you
know what we're going to keep it very
limited because that's a way we can kind
of crack a deal with you guys as the
american people in order to get this out
there but as we've seen them today the
democrats today celebrate nine month
abortions governor cuomo in new york lit
up the freedom tower pink to celebrate
nine month abortions for no medical
reason
i've seen ralph northam talk about you
know keeping the baby comfortable after
it's born and then a discussion ensuing
as to what would happen to it next so
when we really go into it there there
isn't too much middle ground on it
either this is a human life and this is
a person
or this is quote a cluster of cells an
appendix a body part as they like to say
not worthy of protection so i think that
people are actually realizing that that
whole middle ground ideology
as you were saying safely and rare
doesn't actually make any sense because
we're talking about either life or death
when it comes to this human being
you know right now we're about 50 50 in
the country on people who support
abortion and people who oppose it which
is better than we were in past decades
there have been times when when people
were much more in favor of abortion but
we seem to have deadlocked around 50 50.
is this just one of those issues that
we're not going to resolve that we're
basically going to be in a stalemate
forever or is there some hope that we're
going to convince people to stop
allowing the legal killing of babies
yeah i don't think so i think it's a
little more nuanced i think the polls
have shown that over 75 percent of
americans are against late term abortion
they're against federal funding for
abortion and so i think that we could
actually come to a place where most
americans could agree maybe on a
heartbeat bill or some other kind of
limitation and then we could discuss
okay maybe we should make our
discussions more surrounding something
like that but in any case most americans
look at a baby at nine months and say
wow you know this really is a
full-fledged human this is a
full-fledged baby in order to kill this
child it's going to be a very big effort
so i think that there's um um actually a
lot of support for that for as far as
most americans who are not even
necessarily pro-life um from the moment
of conception i'd be curious to hear
because i know you like to steal man you
know the other people's arguments here
what do you think is the strongest
argument
for abortion what's the best argument
that they have at their disposal
well i would say most pro-lifers would
probably agree that when they bring up
kind of the hard cases maybe cases of
rape cases of incest things like that i
would say those are um especially
heartbreaking because uh you know all of
us are against that of having ever
occurred in the first place but i think
that um the main thing to keep in mind
is the fact that all of those hard case
exceptions mean when we look at incest
it's less than 0.01 of the time rape is
usually less than one percent of the
time so we're talking about very rare
instances and the left of course doesn't
say hey we're gonna go i'm going to be
against abortion in all other cases
except for this no you know if you said
okay you know not not not in that
situation they would still be for
abortion but even if we zoom in on that
i think what's most disturbing is the
fact that people on the left advocate
for the death penalty for the child and
not for the rapist and of course the
child had absolutely nothing to do with
that action but they actually want you
know lighter crime sentences and you
know they're against things like that
for rapists serial killers so i think in
order to stop that we have to stop you
know the rape from occurring in the
first place
sure it's a great point you bring up
that they they're crying about the death
penalty for all sorts of awful killers
and rapists and yet when we're talking
about the death penalty with no due
process for little babies they're
perfectly fine with that
this issue of the hard cases too you
bring up it it accounts for so few
abortions every year
and yet we always hear from the left
when we bring up their support of
abortion in in the ninth month in the
third trimester
if you're in the case of the virginia
governor ralph northam he suggested we
have fourth trimester abortions he
suggested the baby could be born and you
could still kill it and what they say to
conservatives is
oh gosh come off it there are so few
abortions that happen in those cases
maybe that's true but then how come they
keep making making their arguments in
the extreme all the way on the other end
in
what accounts for less than one percent
of abortions